putin recibe al presidente bielorruso en
sochi es un respaldo público o un aliado
acusado por la europea de piratería
estatal después de que quisiese
aterrizar un avión de ryanair y arrestar
a un periodista disidente
recordemos que vladímir putin tendrá en
cuestión de semanas una cumbre histórica
con el presidente estadounidense joe
biden se espera que discutan las
tensiones sobre el conflicto de ucrania
el armamento estratégico también y los
ataques cibernéticos pero putin ahora
está poniendo sobre la mesa su apoyo a
bielorrusia y además poniendo de alguna
manera límites a esa presión occidental
la unión europea está preparando una
escalada de sanciones contra el régimen
de lukashenko y el apoyo de putin a una
persona que es considerada el último
dictador de europa es muy controvertido
hay que recordar que vladimir putin
respaldó la represión de lukashenko
contra las protestas cuando ocurrieron
las manifestaciones después de las
disputadas y controvertidas elecciones
presidenciales del año pasado en
bielorrusia